well the city of north las vegas is  encouraging people to disconnect and  have some fun they hosted their unplug  and play toys event at liberty park  today children were able to turn off  their devices and play soccer some got  to hula hoop and also enjoy some water  games  it's just important to me because we  want you to relax be a kid be an  indulgence you know come and enjoy the  fun things in life without having to  depend on technology to make that fun  happen  all right so there was also a huge toy  giveaway we're told children took home  some goodies such as  legos and board games among other prizes  and it's just always fun to be outside  it just takes him taking some fresh